[Musica]
il futuro è un argomento che mi ha
sempre interessato
anzi direi affascinato tanto che poi
diventata parte della mia professione
ordinaria ma tutto nasce quando ho sei
anni circa
mi sono appassionata una serie tv
inglese spazio 1999
non so se qualcuno lo possa ricordare ma
si parlava era di una stazione lunare
con scienziati in orbita nello spazio
vedere navette spaziali alieni incontri
di diverso genere ha iniziato a farmi
navigare con anche con la fantasia e
all'età di sei anni
mi ero immaginato vecchio a 27 anni nel
1999 perché per un bambino aveva 27 anni
essere vecchi mi immaginavo già di
andare per la città su una macchina
volante però ci vogliono pochi anni per
capire che quello quell idea di futuro
che mi hanno fatto mio il fatto non era
difficilmente realizzabile da qui cioè
entro il 99 ma comunque l'interesse per
futuro era attivato a 19 anni iniziai a
studiare economia
anzi ero immerso negli studi di economia
dove la programmazione e il controllo è
una parte importante dello studio e
nonostante andassi andassi a passo
spedito arner raggiungere tutti gli
obiettivi che vi che mi mettevo in
agenda rimarrà sempre un amaro in bocca
che diceva ok spingiti più in là
spingiti più in là spingiti più in là la
strada sembra che ci fosse un angolo
dopo l'angolo ci sarà quello che tu la
puoi raggiungere ma dopo dietro quell
angolo c'era un altro angolo e penso che
così
mille chiacchierate con amici era un
aspetto comune ma chiacchierando con
un'amica straniera le mi disse leggi
questo libro e lo sto a posto
lo sto studiando e molto interessante
era un libro di yoga e così è nato un
interesse molto particolare per questa
disciplina ma 28 anni fa non era così
semplice studiare yoga tantomeno
praticarlo non c'era non c'era internet
non c'erano social media di quelli
attuali con il quale scambiare con
informazioni rilevanti non c'erano in
sardegna corsi strutturati di yoga per
cui si andava lentamente si progrediva
lentamente negli studi e nella pratica
ma nonostante tutto la dedizione
aumentata come un fuoco alimentato con
legna secca e allora ciò che circolava
in giro erano più che altro favolette
naif e per cui le persone che non
conoscevano niente erano ignoranti in
questo senso di vista perché perché non
conoscevano mi guardavano come un
animale un po pericoloso e quindi al di
là del fatto che sul mio volto ci fosse
sempre più un sorriso sincero anziché un
broncio questo non non era sufficiente
però il tempo il tempo stava passando
e quindi voi che vuoi per il fatto che c
c'erano molti cannes sempre più cantanti
e attori internazionali che raccontavano
i benefici incredibili psicofisici
ottenuti tramite lo yoga voi che anche
addirittura siamo arrivati nel 2014 che
l'onu ha dichiarato individuato il 21
giugno come giornata mondiale dello yoga
in 193 paesi del mondo il 21 giugno
solstizio d'estate è giornata dedicata
durate internazione dello yoga e
addirittura nel 2016
l'unesco ha inserito il patrimonio lo
yoga come nella sua lista di patrimoni
dell'umanità quindi diciamo un argomento
che è diventato di uso comune
ma cos'è questo yoga per i più forse
potrebbe essere una una disciplina che
rende flessibili come le ginnasti o
ringiovanisce il corpo è vivo e il volto
come alcuni cantanti fanno pensare
oppure è come si vede nelle pubblicità e
su riviste in tv quell aspetto che fatti
fare ti consente di mangiare delle
merendine e snack rimanendo sereno e con
un sorriso e statico con cu o ancora
come qualche cantante anni fa disse è
ciò che ti consente di avere delle
performance sessuali incredibili
incredibilmente lunga quindi ancora un
po di incertezza o di fumi su questa su
questa disciplina ma
lo yoga è un qualcosa un po più di
complesso e articolato da rappresentare
quindi ve lo spiegherò nel modo più
semplice possibile
innanzitutto è una disciplina nata in
india è inizialmente anticamente
tramandata da un muro cioè il maestro ha
pochissimi allievi predestinati
era un insegnamento di tipo orale
tramandato oralmente ma finalmente dal
primo secolo avanti cristo in poi sono
iniziati a trovarsi degli iscritti e c'è
stata un'evoluzione nei secoli e
creazione di nuovi metodi sino
addirittura al secolo scorso con nuovi
metri che sono per lo più conosciuti
addirittura praticati più in occidente
che che in india
ma che cos'è questo yoga quali sono i
suoi principi
il lo yoga insegna con la pratica a
vedere ea percepire ea vivere la vita
ciascuno come un unicum un composto da
corpo mente e spirito
a livello individuale ma a livello anche
di connessione tra l'individuo e tutto
ciò che di circo che lo circonda con la
natura stessa è l'unione tra tutti
questi elementi
tutto questo è un unicum non c'è una
separazione a livello didattico si è
necessario far passare questa
separazione ma nella pratica si scopre
che questa separazione non c'è si
percepisce che non c'è un altro elemento
ed è per questo che oggi parlo è la
concezione del tempo che fa è insita
nell'insegnamento nella pratica nel
vivere allo yoga e il presente è la fed
è il momento della ricerca il passato e
il futuro sono dei concetti il presente
è e ciò che esiste realmente
lo yoga è questo unico questo questa
unione di tra corpo mente e spirito
si presenta come allineamento
l'allineamento tra queste parti e da
questo allineamento discende equilibrio
benessere e sviluppo di tutte le
potenzialità dell'essere umano vivendo
in natura siamo abituati a vivere il
mondo dual e cell plus e l'allineamento
è equilibrio benessere e sviluppo delle
potenzialità
il disequilibrio è l'opposto e quindi e
mancanza di riallineamento mancanza di
rilassamento mancanza di benessere
quindi l'opposto alla all'allineamento
il disallineamento il disallineamento
crea tensione è una tensione può essere
fisica psicologica psichica emozionale
nello yoga appunto tutto è tutto è unito
una tensione fisica è unita alla è
collegata strettamente alla alla
tensione emotiva e quindi quando si
vuole insegnare o praticare lo yoga
questa è l'attenzione come si pratica
con insieme di metodi e in questo lo
yoga è una tecnologia in che senso
perché utilizza degli strumenti degli
strumenti in particolare che gli
spiegherò le brevissimamente in modo da
risolvere dei problemi pratici
questa è anche la definizione di e
tecnologia comune solamente che siamo
abituati a utilizzare gli strumenti
tecnologici che noi affermiamo quindi
alcuni di questi strumenti possono
essere anzi sono
principi etico morali che guidano la
nostra vita nel porci nel porci di
fronte a noi stessi ma anche nei
confronti della società
le posture le posizioni che in sanscrito
chiediamo la sana esercizi di controllo
del respiro esercizi di controllo della
concentrazione della della meditazione e
così via
tutti strumenti che ci consentono di
vivere il presente come ricerca
dell'allineamento un esempio partendo
dalla sana che io insegno nella prima
lezione quando una persona arriva a
lezione per sperimentare ciò che non
insegna subito ma spiegherò nel tempo se
la persona continua a praticare la da
sana
la postura la postura del dl del corpo è
a seconda delle tensioni che si creano
fuori asse l'asse è idealmente una linea
che passa dalla sommità della testa
segue la colonna vertebrale sino al
centro di piedi quello il nostro asse il
corpo angeli mentre allineata test
allineata sguardo verso l'orizzonte che
io posso osservarmi cosa accade in me
agli stimoli
ma cosa accade in me se io penso al
futuro è possibile che io inizi a
sentire una tensione perché perché la
mia idea va al futuro e cosa accade
quando va al futuro inizio a
immedesimarmi in quell idea oppure penso
al passato e vengo come trascinato verso
quell idea e non il mio momento presente
che posso vivere stando sui miti e di
stando con la testa sul collo
e allora succederà questo un bambino
nasce vi invito a l'invito riuscire qua
s e di sfidare le leggi della statistica
visto che in sardegna la natalità ormai
è sotto zero
quindi è possibile che sia difficile
trovare un bambino di un anno
osservate la sua la sua vita a un
passato molto breve ha poche influenze
poca spinta la di attrazione e indietro
perché verso il passato però volevo
scoprire il futuro
lo vedrete piedi i varchi busto eretto e
vorrà andare verso avanti stando sui
suoi piedi un un ragazzo probabilmente
vuole andare alla scoperta del mondo che
andrà in avanti
e poi col passare del tempo si va fuori
asse è un disequilibrio visivamente si
vive questo disequilibrio nella nostra
pratica ci abituiamo a riandare in
equilibrio ea stare presenti a noi
stessi
in quel momento sapendo che il futuro
esiste lo dobbiamo programmare perfetto
abbiamo degli obiettivi perfetto
altrimenti non sarei qua tutti quanti
abbiamo degli obiettivi ma abbiamo la
possibilità di vivere come sequenza di
momenti successivi dal presente e quindi
un semplice esempio se io vi dico vi do
delle indicazioni probabilmente
sentirete un'attrazione in base anche
alla vostra storia
in base alla vostra storia avrete avrete
aspettative avrete paure avrete timori
avete potra test sentivi galvanizzati
per questa idea se vi dicessi appunto
che come dice mckinsey la società di
consulenza nel 2018 ha pubblicato un
report nel quale nel quale si dice che
entro il 2030 il 33 per cento dei lavori
attuali non esisterà più
cosa vi di cosa succede cosa accade se
vi dico che entro il 2010 ci saranno
tante città del mondo in cina negli
emirati arabi uniti in corea dove le
smart city saranno pienamente realizzate
e dove tutti potranno vivere in modo più
eco friendly la vostra nazione
probabilmente si stanno stimolando
un'attenzione una come una calamita
siete attivati e allora l'invito è
nuovamente
a trovare il centro per poter prendere
decisioni ma vivere il momento dopo
momento
l'invito è semplicemente piedi dritti
sulla tia il tronco e sul torace scapole
piatte sulla schiena e stendete guardate
l'orizzonte calmate il respiro e
osservate namastè
[Musica]
[Applauso]